[Musique]
c'est le faire pour faire arriver et
c'est ça la bonne mais qu'est ce que
l'amour alors qu'une exposition au
palais de la découverte à paris tente de
répondre
revenons sur 50 ans de paroles d'enfants
autour de la question en 1966 eric avec
quatre ans il était déjà marié j'ai bien
envie depuis longtemps et yelp et
gascogne la colère l'amour ce n'est pas
qu'une histoire d'adultes les enfants on
parle aussi bien que les grands il ya un
très joli sourire si elle voit deux
héros campé kalluri mais le premier
amour reste celui pour sa maman
une déclaration pour la fête des mères
ce 31 mai 1970 la fête à toutes les
mamans tous les ans nous fais tes
baisers l'amour et ses baisers pour les
scientifiques l'amour serait une
question de fluides de molécules
d'hormones et de circuits neuronaux mais
peut-être que c'est bien plus sans que
ça quand on sent qu'on est amoureux
c'est on a les mains moites on bientôt
rouge qui auribot c'est un truc tout
bête on pense qu'à y casser qu'on aime
ou celle que même au fait des rêves ont
fait des cauchemars où on peut plus bas
on peut plus on sait plus quoi faire
enfin on peut aimer quelqu un à six ans
que ce soit réciproque donc on essaye de
patron de pas trop le montrer
et puis les enfants deviennent ados ils
découvrent les tourments amoureux le
manque
il parle en silence ou en contradiction
qu'est ce qu'on ressent quand on est
amoureuse ben je sais pas on est souvent
aussi
mais dès qu'on se retrouve seul c'est
c'est un peu comme si y'avait personne
un seul être vous manque et tout est
dépeuplé
comme le disait lamartine et comme le
poète quelques vers chantés ou réciter
pour entretenir la flamme
ça fait toujours chaud au coeur
je ne peux pas fermer
mais pas
[Musique]